I've been rereading by genetic summary that I had done a few years ago and I have, so this person has been a patient for three, four or five years and we did a genetic workup back then and that time we did not give.
And now when we do a genetic workup, we give the full report and now the full report because it's more genes that we look at. I think when this person did their full report, there was the full report was probably like 90 pages.
Now the full report is over 250 pages.
Same font as before that's just how many more genes were looking at now and then now we give a full report plus I give a condensed report or what is called a genetic summary report.
So on the genetic summary report we see I break down that full report into more bite size pieces and highlight the main genes that we want to look at.
And then I also then give what's called an action step report. So the full reports about 270 or 250 pages, the genetic summary reports about 17 18 pages and the genetic action step report is just about three pages.
So that just gives you here's your action steps and a lot of people will just like, okay, just show me what to do. So that's all you really need to read.
You also have the ability if you really want to dirt out genetics, you can you can look at the full report, you can go over the the you have access to the read your genes course, you can look at all the videos that I made on the read your genes course, you can dig into it even further if you want.
If you say it's important to know the big picture we're talking about supplements and currently very interested in knowing if I should add these two supplements to my regiment pro SOD canalace and so forth as I'm so pro SOD canalace is a PHP product that has SOD that stands for super oxide dispute case and canalace so these are the two enzymes super oxide dispute case ever that ends in an ace.
Canalace ends in an ace and it ends in an ace like that is an enzyme those are enzymes that break down proxy nitrate issues.
So proxy nitrate is a very strong oxidant that can cause cancer.
So you can't go wrong taking SOD and canalace I mean that's not something so.
Remember I say I don't watch out too many supplements because your liver has to detoxify him if you're taking too much stuff well that's really what I'm talking about is like herbal things and you know we're going to take some other herbal product then if you body can't use that you absorb it then your liver has to get rid of it, but when you're talking about enzymes you can't really take too many enzymes you just can't your body will use those it'll break it down.
It'll break it down into proteins you'll use it to make other enzymes if it doesn't eat that enzymes so you can't really over do dose enzymes it's not really possible.
And then so yes you could take that now you are believe I you were taking other things that had SOD canalace in it so it was just trying to keep you to lesser amount of supplements.
So for as I'm is a product from US enzymes it's got so for a fade so for a fade is the main product in broccoli extracts that can help with estrogen dominance and helpful estrogens out and can be great for estrogen dominant cancers now I believe you're taking other things to do the same thing and you're taking other things that probably have.
In it and then because it's a US enzyme product all US enzyme products also have.
At least astroside which is their patented enzyme if not other enzymes as well so you could take these there's no negative about that.
So I believe the SOD effects copper well really SOD really pulls out.
Approxidite trait so proxidite trait is really broken down through the SOD through SOD and canalace.